in this lesson we're going to talk about
how to find arc length so the formula
for arc length is this one right here
it's the central angle divided by 360
times 2 pi r so 2 pi r is basically the
circumference of a circle right and then
theta divided by 360 is the fraction of
the entire circle so for example if
theta was 180 degrees that would be one
half of the circumference so you'd just
be finding you know half the distance
all the way around the outer edge so a
good formula to understand and remember
but go ahead and see if you can do this
problem here it says find the length of
this arc okay and they give us the
central angles 30 degrees they give us
the radius is 4 inches how would we find
the arc length
well essentially what we're going to do
here is we're just going to substitute
so we've got 30 over 360
times 2 pi and the radius is 4. so you
can see 30 divided by 360 is actually 1
12. this is actually 1 12 of the entire
circumference
times 2 times pi times 4 is 8 pi
and you can think of that as being over
1 anything divided by 1 is itself and so
we have 8 pi over 12 which if we reduce
4 goes into both of these that would be
2 pi
over 3 and in this case it's going to be
inches because we're just working with
the length so a good formula remember
and understand and i'll see you in the
next lesson